العثور على ارقامه هواتف الشركات الكبرى
بعد امرا اقرب الى المستحيل وحتى اذا حصلت
عليه فلن تتحدث الى شخص طبيعي بل الى
المجيب الالي استطلاعون اجرتهم وين كنت
وشمله 1200 شخص في صحيفه وصف جينل اظهر ان
نصف المستجيبين تقريبا اضطروا الى البحث
لوقت طويل في موقع شركه للعثور على رقم
هاتف في حين قال 43% انهم يفضلون التحدث
مع موظف خدمه العملاء عبر الهاتف بينما
يفضل خمسه في المئه فقط اتحدث الى نوبات
من خلال الرسائل الفوريه العديد من
الشركات العالميه اسقطت خيار التحدث مع
موظف خدمه الاتصال تماما تركه العملاء
لاستخدام الوظائف او وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لحل المشاكل شركه الطيران
يوتيوب الغاء الخدمه الهاتفيه بان
المكالمات الصوتيه تترك سبيلا للتفاوض مع
العملاء وانت ما رايك هل تفضل الحديث الى
شخص طبيعي ام ان القنوات البديله كحل
المشكله بشكل افضل
[موسيقى]